I was just wondering I agree with you
that like biologically a man is a man
and a woman is a woman I was just
wondering what you see the detriment of
society like why we can't like let a
transgender like woman be called she or
something because it is why I ID so the
wedding there are a couple of reasons
so yeah sorry let me finish the question
I'm just what do you see I understand
it's lying like I was taught not to lie
I just don't understand what is so wrong
about that specific lie well I mean as
opposed to other lies I'm not sure there
is anything wrong I mean I don't like
all yeah but it's but as far as that
specific lie I think that one of the
problems that we have is this this
determination that men can become women
and women can become men undermines some
barriers between men and women that I
think are useful and good particularly
in children so if I have to teach my
three and a half year old right she's
almost 4 if I teach my almost 4 year old
girl that she can become a boy then I
think that is not only lying to her I
think it's confusing her and I think
it's damaging to her psyche one of the
one of the premises of the transgender
movement is that human minds are
completely non malleable that that oddly
enough men and men are not men and women
are not women but if you are transgender
that is unchangeable and then especially
among children if the 3 or 4 year old
has certain feelings those feelings have
to be taking completely seriously we
can't fight against them
we can't suggest that the kid will grow
out of it instead we have to say that
this kid is inherently transgender I can
tell you having kids kids are incredibly
malleable kids are easily confused and
saying to a child which is what the
transgender movement would like to do I
mean they're having drag shows in
kindergarten now in some areas you know
when you do that when you confuse kids
about about gender you're doing the kids
no favors you're doing them significant
down or you could be doing significant
damage the kids kids should not be
confused about their biology kids should
not be confused about their gender and
let's put it this way just from a
certain statistical standpoint if it is
true that the transgender suicide
attempt rate is 40% over the lifetime
and if I am right then more kids will be
confused about gender which by the way
you do see you've seen that an uptick in
transgender surgery in in Europe you've
seen a greater identification as
transgender overall in place like you're
at malleable rates of transgenderism in
Europe if that's the case then you are
raising the suicide rates presumably if
there's an association between for young
people who are now confused about gender
so I am not in the mood for
countenancing
eyes about about what men and women are
specifically when I think that there is
a goal of redefining a key term for the
entire society